[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà 10 ans que je me suis lancé dans
ma vie professionnelle
disant d'entrepreneuriat
médisant aussi à être ce que j'ai appelé
un SBF
sans bureau fixe je pourrais même dire
SB tout court car je n'ai jamais
vraiment eu de bureau
j'ai bossé dans tous les contextes
possibles et imaginables
tant qu'à fait d'une gare d'une salle de
sport
de métiers
de la forêt tropicale d'une piste de ski
mais aussi parfois je dois l'avouer
peut-être comme certains d'entre vous
également du sas d'isolation
ultime que seuls les parents sa
véritablement apprécié le trône
avouer on y est tranquille quand même
j'ai adoré le mode de vie que m'a permis
cette façon de travailler
j'ai fait le tour du monde
et rencontrer sur la route des amis des
clients des partenaires ma femme mais
aussi et surtout moi-même
et pourtant à chaque fois que je
retournais dans la matrice je redevenais
un ovni un bug une anomalie un autre
hippie
comment expliquer à Fred delaconta qu'il
était totalement possible et
professionnel de bosser face à la mer
entre deux sessions de surf
j'avais l'impression que ce monde
corporate était top cédé par la forme et
non plus le fond
et dans la dissonance cognitive la
plupart faite c'est même entreprises qui
refusaient catégoriquement le travail à
distance à leur salarié me payer moi
pour mon précieux jus de cerveau
lui-même rendu possible par ma vie
nomade
ironique non
et puis un jour
alors que nous étions quelques fous à
marcher à contre-courant l'humanité
s'est arrêtée
puisse s'est mise à avancer côte à côte
avec nous le télétravail s'était imposé
et bosser en caleçon chaussettes depuis
son salon est devenu on ne peut plus
sérieux
j'étais super enthousiaste quand j'ai vu
ce changement sur le terrain
je me suis dit qu'en fin le monde de
l'entreprise c'était réveillé et avait
réclamé d'une seule voix on veut le
futur of work
à la place on a les zoom
et des milliers d'heures de Visio
flicage un an plus finir alors
évidemment je ne crache pas sur ces
formidables outils qui nous ont permis
de basculer aussi vite au contraire
néanmoins passer de métro boulot dodo à
visio frigo solo très rapidement kilo
c'est pas forcément le renouveau que je
souhaitais voir émerger
très rapidement
je me suis dit que
monde du travail plus souhaitable était
possible et qu'il était possible de
travailler non seulement de son foyer
mais aussi et surtout ailleurs et c'est
cette nuance qui j'en suis convaincu à
le potentiel de changer nos sociétés
pour le meilleur
comment c'est simple d'abord en
remettant le flot au cœur du travail un
bon travail nécessite un bon contexte tu
te souviens peut-être de cette session
de brainstorming hyper efficace que tu
as eu à la machine à café avec ton
collègue ou encore ce moment de
concentration ultime que tu avais à la
BU quand tu étais encore étudiant ou
simplement ce sentiment d'appartenance
et de camaraderie que tu ressens quand
tu travailles dans la bonne humeur
entouré de ton équipe
dans tous ces moments là
tu étais dans
la zone
cet endroit magique ou sans effort le
temps s'efface et tu travailles
efficacement mais surtout avec plaisir
et parce qu'il existe plusieurs types de
tâches dans un même métier tu as besoin
de différents contextes pour accéder à
cette zone
faisons un petit exercice
imaginons à quoi pourrait ressembler une
semaine type si on y remettait
véritablement de la flexibilité
le lundi tu reviens d'un week-end plutôt
sympa à la rivière en famille tu restes
à la maison tu enchaînes les visio avec
tes collègues et tout se passe bien le
mardi tu dois travailler sur des tâches
de fond ça te demande de te concentrer
sans distraction sur des périodes de 3 à
4 heures on appelle ça du de poids du
travail profond et le faire depuis une
salle isolée et totalement adapté
d'ailleurs je sais pas pour vous mais en
parlant de concentration et de poids je
pense qu'il existe une place bien
spécifique en enfer pour toute personne
qui vous dira qu'il est totalement
possible de se concentrer plus de 10
minutes avec vos gosses en pleine
démence dans le fond c'est le meilleur
moyen de développer de l'urticaire et de
perdre en espérance de vie croyez-moi
faut arrêter ça
mais retournons à notre semaine
le mercredi tu attaques des tâches
légères elles te prennent 15 à 20
minutes chacune envoyer un email
consulter un document posté sur les
réseaux on appelle ça du shalow work du
travail de surface et le faire depuis un
espace de coworking est totalement
adapté tu en profiteras d'ailleurs pour
faire un peu de réseau et emmener ta
fille au judo à 16h
le jeudi tu souhaites collaborer
tu es donc de retour au bureau ou dans
une salle équipée et enfin le vendredi
tu cherches à être créatif tu cherches à
être inspiré et t'installer face à une
vue dégagée ou simplement dans ton café
préféré sera ta meilleure Muse
et là vous allez me dire et le bureau
dans tout ça le bureau est mort non
le bureau n'est pas mort c'est le bureau
d'avant qui est mort il ne remplit
simplement plus simplement une fonction
de production mais bel et bien de plus
en plus une fonction de commodité c'est
une infrastructure qui a la disposition
de vos équipes une fonction de
collaboration vos salariés s'y
retrouvent pour travailler ensemble et
enfin une fonction de sociabilisation
c'est un lieu totem qui cristallise la
culture de votre entreprise
vous imaginez bien que dans ce contexte
si jamais vous souhaitez voir vos
salariés se repenter dans vos locaux
c'est l'expérience même du bureau que
vous devez travailler avec intention et
conscience
oui j'en suis persuadé il existe une
intelligence des espaces et dès lors
qu'ils sont bien pensés bien aménagés
bien animés la magie opère
c'est justement dans ce nouveau
paradigme
j'en suis convaincu
que l'on a à portée de main les fruits
les premiers pas qui vont nous permettre
d'adresser les défis principaux de notre
époque
en décentralisant et en libérant le
travail ce sont nos routes que nous
désengorgeons nos villes dortoirs que
nous réveillons nos petits commerces que
nous ressuscitons mais aussi notre
rapport à notre environnement direct qui
évolue
alors
si jamais dans la salle on a des
dirigeants des managers des chefs
d'entreprise toute personne qui pourrait
changer les choses
de grâce
arrêtez d'investir sur des mètres carrés
de béton
et miser enfin sur l'humain et la
confiance
il représente les ingrédients
indispensables dans futur du travail
souhaitable dans ce monde après zoom
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]